[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend
masken gegner sieben tage incidents
boostern 2g 3g ft2 fp3 begriffe auf die
man noch vor zwei jahren verständnislos
reagiert hätte inzwischen zeigt man auch
nicht mehr wenn von einem hybriden
parteitag die rede ist einen solchen
hielt die spd heute ab die
parteiprominenz war vor ort in berlin
die meisten der über 600 delegierten nur
zugeschaltet von der wahl der neuen
parteispitze und des neuen
generalsekretärs verspricht sich die spd
einerseits verjüngung und neue impulse
andererseits ausgleich und befriedung
christian von rechenberg war für uns in
berlin ja ich nehme die wahl sehr gerne
an wenn ich danke für euer vertrauen ich
nehme die wahl sehr gerne an vielen dank
für das vertrauen das harmoniert bereits
das neue spitzenduo saskia esken und
lars klingbeil nur im ergebnis etwas
auseinander esken knapp 77 prozent
klingen bei 86 ihm dank die partei heute
auch den gelungenen wahlkampf ich freue
mich darauf auf der anderen seite habe
ich aber auch ganz viel respekt und ich
habe aber auch viel vor mit meiner
partei will der spd prägen wir haben in
den letzten zwei jahren erfolgreich weil
wir einen bestimmten stil auch
verkörpert haben weil wir geschlossen
waren weil wir uns im alltagsthemen
gekümmert haben klingen weil architekt
eben jener geschlossenheit für seinen
sanften stilen der kritischen phase des
spd wahlkampfs kritisiert sollte sich
das sich bestätigt reklamiert
gestaltungsanspruch der spd ruft gar ein
sozialdemokratisches jahrzehnt aus was
nur im team möglich sei klingenberg kann
in der weg in eine gute zukunft der
führt überbrücken der geht nicht durch
gräben führung und gute führung macht
nicht aus dass man maulheld ist und alle
antworten schon immer weiß das ist
zugegebenermaßen oft kein lauter prozess
habe ich sage euch es ist ein sehr
kraftvoller und das ist mein weg
seiner bisher weniger kevin kühnert
immer müder rebell der die groko stoppen
wollte scholz als vorsitzenden mit
gestoppt hat sucht eine neue rolle und
er wird sie bekommen möchte alles dafür
geben der sozialdemokratischen partei
ihrer sache ihren beschlüssen und ihren
aktuell so stolzen mitgliedern in den
kommenden zwei jahren als
generalsekretär dienen zu dürfen er darf
die partei gibt ihm ein solides mandat
kabel 1 mit dem kanzler soll es mit ihm
als generalsekretär nicht geben und doch
kündigt grüner damm themen
nachzuschärfen wenn es sein muss wenn
denn gleich eine handvoll doch keine
widerspenstigen zähmung und kann einige
den eindruck haben der cunard wird
angepasst dann werden die mir das schon
mitteilen bin aber sehr optimistisch
dass man in einer linken volkspartei das
ist die spd kritischer geist bleiben
kann und störenfried deswegen zu werden
stören könnten andere die jusos etwa
formulieren bei der vermögensverteilung
bereits forderungen da müssen wir uns
weiter einmischen und ich hoffe dass die
fdp ehrlich gesagt mal auf ein paar
erkenntnisse stößt denn das garantiert
den zusammenhalt in der gesellschaft und
das was wir jetzt erleben ist einfach
nicht gerecht ist es wird womöglich
gegenwind geben
olaf scholz heute mit einer kanzelrede
respekt sein thema mut und eine
ermahnung
die bürgern bürger müssen das gefühl
entwickeln und das vertrauen das was
öffentlich gesagt wird hinterher auch
umgesetzt wird in der politik ich
geschlossenheit hast die spd ins
kanzleramt gebracht so zeigte sie sich
auch heute mit neuer verjüngter spitze
derweil war außenministerin annalena
baerbock heute auf einer art
internationalem speed dating beim
außenministertreffen der g 7 in
liverpool lernte sie auf einen schlag
die kolleginnen und kollegen der
wichtigsten partnerstaaten kennen die
sieben führenden industriestaaten
verstehen sich nicht nur als
wirtschaftsmächte sondern auch als
wertegemeinschaft
deshalb sagt man ja auch nicht mehr im
g8 format mit russland damit ist es seit
2014 vorbei seit der annexion der krim
in der ukraine konflikt ist geblieben
und heute wieder ganz oben auf der
tagesordnung andreas künast hat die neue
deutsche außenminister nach liverpool
begleitet
wenn man plötzlich im fokus der
weltpresse steht in einer der
mächtigsten runden der diplomatie kann
es nicht schaden einen im rücken zu
haben der schon alles erlebt und alles
verhandelt hat in liverpool sitzt jens
plötner der politische direktor des
auswärtigen amts hinter ministerin
bernburg was pluspunkt und
ausrufezeichen ist jetzt wird es ernst
die usa drängen deutschland zum
diplomatischen boykott der olympischen
spiele in china italien ist er dagegen
großbritannien drängt werburg nord
stream 2 zu verhindern japan drängt zu
mehr härte gegen china es gibt keine
schonfrist für das teamwork plötner die
stimmung unter den g7 ist ernst
wir müssen uns gegen die wachsenden
bedrohungen durch feindliche akteure
wären wir müssen uns gemeinsam stark
machen um den aggressoren die stirn zu
bieten die versuchen die grenzen von
freiheit und demokratie einzuschränken
für liverpool für die stadt der vorhaben
die g7 heute keine zeit und keinen blick
obwohl sie im liverpool museum tagen für
annalena baerbock ist die erste woche im
amt eine endlose aneinanderreihung
kaster treffen 30 minuten italien 30
minuten großbritannien dann japan und so
weiter top diplomat blödtner ist immer
dabei und sieht zumindest nicht
unglücklich aus das ist der job einer
außenministerin dass man keine zeit fürs
lang einstieg hat und deswegen habe ich
auch ganz bewusst ein einstieg gewählt
indem ich direkt alle entscheidenden
außenministerin und außenminister jetzt
getroffen habe einseitige festlegungen
muss berbalk vermeiden aussagen die den
koalitionsfrieden stören auch dass der
neue bundeskanzler
außenpolitik als chefsache sieht zeigt
scholz indem er jens plötner vom
außenamt ins kanzleramt als obersten
außenpolitischen berater bleibt die
frage ob die neue am g7 tisch überhaupt
neue akzente setzen konnte
doch konnten wir und konnte ich das
betrifft den klimaschutz betrifft eben
genauso geostrategische fragen wo rein
investieren wir eigentlich in welche
regionen und wie können wir da liberale
demokratien stärken in drei wochen geht
die britische t 7 präsidentschaft zu
ende im nächsten jahr heißt der
gastgeber deutschland und die
gastgeberin werbung
weiter geht's in den nachrichten in den
usa gab es verheerende wirbelstürme mit
vielen todesopfern heinz ja diese
wirbelstürme sind über mehrere
bundesstaaten hinweg gezogen besonders
schwer betroffen ist kentucky und die
behörden befürchten dass allein dort
mindestens 70 menschen ums leben
gekommen sind
ein trümmerfeld wo einmal eine
kerzenfabrik war über 100 menschen
arbeiteten dort als der sturm mayfield
kentucky traf viele werden noch vermisst
ich will meine frau finden ich hoffe sie
ist in sicherheit
bitte ruf mich an sobald du kannst
das historische zentrum von mayfield
gleicht einem kriegsschauplatz die
kleinstadt im südosten der usa komplett
zerstört
das waren die schlimmsten
verheerendsten und tödlichsten tornados
in der geschichte von kentucky
auch andere bundesstaaten wurden von den
mehr als 30 tornados verwüstet in
illinois stürzte das dach eines amazon
verteilzentrums 1 auch hier gab es tote
der us-präsident verspricht hilfe
es ist eine tragödie und wir wissen
immer noch nicht wie viele menschen wir
verloren haben oder welches ausmaß die
zerstörung hat aber ich möchte betonen
die regierung wird alles tun um zu
helfen
in den trümmern suchen die menschen noch
nach überlebenden
aber die zahl der toten könnte weiter
steigen
nach deutschland zur krone situation und
den aktuellen zahlen das robert koch
institut meldet 53 1697
neuinfektionen an einem tag zehn 1813
weniger als vor einer woche 510
todesfälle kamen hinzu die inzidenz
sinkt auf 4
102,9
in mehreren städten deutschlands haben
heute menschen gegen die krone maßnahmen
und die pandemie politik demonstriert in
hamburg waren nach angaben der polizei
rund 8000 demonstranten unterwegs die
kundgebung in der innenstadt verlief
friedlich jeweils rund 2000 menschen
beteiligten sich hinführt und neumarkt
in der oberpfalz an demonstrationen
derweil wächst die sorge über die sich
rasant ausbreitende variante omikron
großbritannien das uns in der
vergangenheit ja auch schon mit einigem
zeitlich voraus war verzeichnet bereits
hohe raten britische forscher vermuten
dass omikron schon im laufe der nächsten
tage zum dominanten virustyp wird das
wachstum dieser variante ist rasant das
hatte sich schon in südafrika gezeigt
die britische regierung hat auch wieder
ein dämmungsmaßnahmen verhängt und heute
blickt das land auf eine neue studie
seiner besten modellierer wenn man die
szenarien sich ansieht versteht man
warum auch bei uns wissenschaftler vor
dem januar waren aus london erst in
herne
sie haben bei corona ja schon öfter die
wellen ganz vorne geritten die briten ob
bei beta der damals noch kennt genannten
variante vor rund einem jahr oder später
bei delta nun aber scheint es als wenn
auch omikron sich auf der insel rasant
verbreiten und zu erheblichen problemen
führen wird laut einer studie könnte
omikron wenn keine zusätzlichen
maßnahmen ergriffen werden im besten
fall zu rund 25.000 weiteren todesfällen
diesen winter führen im schlimmsten fall
gar zu 75.000 basierend auf der annahme
dass omikron genau so gefährlich ist wie
delta was allerdings noch nicht sicher
ist
einer der gründe weshalb wir annehmen
dass omikron zu weniger schweren
krankheitsverläufen führen könnte ist
dass die variante bisher vorwiegend auf
genesene oder geimpfte getroffen ist
das haben wir aber in unserem modell
bereits berücksichtigt und sehen dennoch
eine ziemlich substanzielle welle an
krankenhaus einweisungen und leider auch
todesfällen auf uns zukommen
die studie des angesehenen londoner
forschungsinstituts ist noch nicht von
fachkollegen umfassend begutachtet
worden sorgt aber bereits für
erheblichen diskussionsstoff
selbst wenn in einer starken welle viele
nur leichte symptome entwickeln ist dies
trotzdem genug um das gesundheitssystem
komplett zu überlasten
seit dem sogenannten freedom day im juli
hat großbritannien konstant hohe
infektionszahlen mit um die 40 bis 50
tausend fällen pro tag was ich aber
nicht den übermäßigen
krankenhauseinweisungen und todesfällen
niederschlug verlassen konnte man sich
darauf ein bis dahin erfolgreiches
impfprogramm mit omikron wird die lage
jetzt komplizierter wenn auch keineswegs
aussichtslos
gegen omikron gibt es nach zwei
impfungen einen geringeren schutz vor
einer ansteckung als es bei delta der
fall war nach einer booster impfung
steigt der allerdings auf über 70
prozent das ist ein guter level und
unterstreicht die wichtigkeit der
dritten impfung
die britische regierung steht vor einem
dilemma nach langer zeit entspannte
handhabe gelten nun etwas strengere
regeln über den sogenannten plan b mit
forcierter masken pflicht und
zugangsbeschränkungen für
großveranstaltungen stimmt das parlament
in der kommenden woche ab und rasch wird
es politisch selbst bei der durchsetzung
dieser milden einschränkungen droht dem
durch zuletzt zahlreiche skandale
angeschlagenen premier johnson eine
rebellion vom rechten flügel seiner
partei
dabei braucht das land so wie es jetzt
aussieht gegen omikron er mindestens
einen plan c
besuch per videoschalte bekam heute der
deutsche astronaut matthias mauer auf
der internationalen raumstation
gemeldet hat sich bundespräsident
steinmeier und zugeschaltet waren
außerdem kinder der stiftung kinderherz
deren botschafter maurer ist der
astronaut der seit mitte november auf
der iss lebt berichtete über seinen
alltag und die arbeit im alb wo er unter
anderem zur herzmedizin forscht
die lottozahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten immer ohne gewähr
19 23 40 46 49 superzahl 0 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 5 56
und noch die wetteraussichten für morgen
im süden bleibt es meist trocken an den
alpen gibt es auch sonne sonst zieht ein
regengebiet von west nach ost dabei kann
es in den östlichen mittelgebirgen
anfangs eisregen geben bei einem
lebhaftem südwestwind werden null bis
elf grad erreicht in den nächsten tagen
stellt sich ruhiges und eher mildes
winterwetter mit hochnebel wenig sonne
und vereinzelt sprühregen an
das war es von uns gleich gehts weiter
mit dem aktuellen sportstudio und danach
um 0.25 gibt es dann die nächste heute
express und uns morgen wieder auf
wiedersehen wieder sinn
[Musik]